yeah just to relief I think I had a very
good position like I had a very big
Advantage maybe even close to winning at
some point but probably I missed
something there uh around the point of
D4 like this Knight F7 D4 I'm not sure
if it's good because he found this
Knight F5 ed4 I think which was very
accurate and um
yeah maybe I had something there but
after that I think it's just a draw like
it's just a very easy draw but okay it
happens in time travel that someone
loses the track you say an easy draw you
had many chances to bail out into a draw
but you kept putting on the pressure how
did you keep control of the nerves yeah
just uh kept the game going and I
thought it's difficult to defend that
position because a pawn is not that
strong I can always go Rook A7 so I I
thought my king is active so I should
try a little bit at least but I was also
trying to make sure that I won't lose
that position with some trick okay it
worked out
all right all the best for the third
game